so deutschland diskutiert heftig darf
sie oder darf sie nicht die rede ist von
klimaaktivisten luisa neubauer wir
denken darüber nach eine pipeline zu
sprengen diesen vermeintlichen scherz
hat luisa neubauer gemacht das deutsche
gesicht der fridays for future bewegung
und damit hat sie die gewünschte
aufmerksamkeit für ein umstrittenes
projekt in afrika bekommen aber die so
unschuldig gestartete schüler bewegung
zugleich auch in öko terrorismusverdacht
gebracht und viele natürlich auch eltern
haben jetzt angst dass sich ihre kinder
und jugendliche in dieser bewegung
radikalisiert
[Musik]
ein schlechter scherz oder aufruf zur
gewalt
[Musik]
gerade planen wir wie wir eine pipeline
in die luft jagen
diese schockierende aussage postel luisa
neubauer in ihrer ins tor die junge
klimaaktivisten ist in dänemark bei
einem so genannten demokratie gipfel es
geht um die zukunft der demokratie doch
wie passt da die androhung von gewalt
zur durchsetzung politischer ziele
ihr wollt es nie gerechtfertigt dann
muss es andere wege geben aber nie mit
gewalt traurig wenn sie steht ja im
öffentlichen leben und sobald ich weiß
gehörte auch eine partei an die zur
region partei zählt und es ist schon
schön ich finde es radikal finde ich
eigentlich nicht in ordnung
dieser neubau ist das deutsche gesicht
von frey des future eine ikone für
millionen jugendliche alleine auf
instagram folgen ihr
366.000 menschen und dann so ein post
luisa neubauer meint eine geplante ruin
pipeline in ostafrika von ugandischen
ölfeldern bis zur küste tansanias knapp
1400 kilometer quer durch
landschaftsschutzgebiete und den
ältesten nationalpark uganda
klar ist der klimaaktivisten und ihren
anhängern das projekt ein dorn im auge
ob auch klar die zu springen die
pipeline existiert noch gar nicht
trotzdem das signal welches louise mit
ihrer aussage in die welt schickt ist
bedenklich also ich würde jetzt
ausleben wollen dass sie dazu
terroristischen attentaten aufrufen
möchte das würde zu weit gehen aber sie
hat muss sich der sache bewusst sein
dass sie zumindest andere leute dazu
verleiten kann denn wir erleben ja in
der klima szene oder bei einigen selbst
ändern klimaschützern dass diese sich
zunehmend radikalisieren dass auch
interne klima szene immer offen dazu
gewalt aufgerufen wird und diese leute
fühlen sich durch solche statements
möglicherweise noch motiviert genau dann
auch die gewaltspirale weiter eskalieren
zu lassen wieder die kalte auf
klimaschutz halten seit monaten
blockieren umweltaktivisten autobahnen
und sorgen mit ihren klima klebe
aktionen für unmut von den gewalttätigen
szenen bei der besetzung des hambacher
forst gar nicht erst zu sprechen
im september 2018 musste ein massives
polizeiaufgebot anrücken um die über
jahre hinweg von klima gegnern in dem
waldstück errichteten baumhäuser zu
räumen und gruppen die die letzte
generation oder extension rebellion
werden offen mit sabotageakten werden
die klimaschützer zu extremisten
feststeht luisas ansage zur pipeline
sprengung ist von instagram verschwunden
auf twitter kommentiert sie ihr zitat
mit jesus maria es ist nur ein buch das
buch mit dem titel wie man eine pipeline
in die luft jagt hält schon länger ein
zug bei jungen klimaschützer
darin ruft der schwedische klima
aktivist andreas meier offen zu
sachbeschädigung und sabotageaktionen
auf feststeht den klimawandel stoppen ja
bitte aber doch nicht mit androhung zur
sabotage und gewalt
die pipeline in die luft einsatz der
also für heftige diskussionen sorgt bild
meinung so viele ps oft er hat sich dazu
in bild live am abend ganz klar
positioniert die frage ist da glaube ich
wo die grenzen liegen und welche grenzen
wir meinen meinen wir grenzen des guten
geschmacks bitte schön aber ich glaube
hier wurde eine rote linie massiv
überschritten denn das was riesa neubau
gesagt hat war offenkundig kein scherz
sie hat sich nämlich auf das buch
berufen das buch das gerade gezeigt
wurde how to blow up pipeline von
andreas mann und sie hat gesagt jesus
maria es ist nur ein buch tja ich glaube
jesus und maria wenn über dieses buch
nicht so glücklich ich hab da heute
nämlich rein gelesen und das ist ein
offener aufruf zu gewalt da werden auch
alle möglichen terror organisationen wie
beispielsweise die palästinensischen
pflp und auch die hamas verherrlicht
verniedlicht werden ihre terrorakte auch
als legitime
widerstands aktion
benannte wird ulrike meinhof die raf-
terroristin und gründerinnen dieser
linksextrem terrororganisationen wird
dazu stimmt zitiert und da werden
vergleiche angestellt die wirklich
einfach nur schwer ist geschmacklos
komplett daneben sind da wird zum
beispiel gesagt die juden im warschauer
ghetto haben sich ja auch gewährt obwohl
sie keine chance hatten gegen die nazis
man könnte die lage dieser juden im
warschauer ghetto auch auf die lage von
klimaaktivisten übertragen und da muss
ich sagen dass es holocaust verhandlung
verharmlosung wenn man anfängt die juden
im holocaust mit der situation von
klimaaktivisten jetzt zu vergleichen
dann ist wirklich jede rote linie
überschritten und frau neubauer sollte
sich dazu positionieren wir haben sie
natürlich angefragt bislang aber keine
antwort bekommen